te jure je lui disais là pendant la pub
on se tutoie on peut se tutoyer tutoiera
mais attends ça ne m'a pas appelé
peuvent faire semblant de blany de la
télévision on est dans le school à des
essais en mer déblais anigo là bas je
sais vous habitez aux états unis c'est
vrai sur l'audace tu me parle anglais
jeu qui freine la voix de petit garçon
[Applaudissements]
e
touche pas à mon poste
[Rires]
los angeles hier victor
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors moi je dis toi d'accord
après les attaques contre vous vont se
voit plus haut soit raymond à mal et non
je suis avec cyril hanouna
mais oui mais là on a fait une soirée
chocola et du coup j'étais band est
obligé de mordre dans n'importe quoi
merci ce que je vais maintenant je
raconte gérald thuru tu peux encore être
là sans toi tu peux dire un petit mot je
veux juste te dire oh marre parce que
peut-être qu'ils n'osent pas
mais si jamais comme j'aimerais bien
faire du cinéma si jamais sa flotte non
mais ça te attends tu saches que
j'accepterai excuse-moi maxime et j'ai
pas compris ta demande si ça te tente ça
ce que j'accepte mais d'après les dire
que j'ai dit que je m'étais même singes
comme le téléphone ne sonne pas beaucoup
et que j'aimerais bien faire du cinéma
si jamais tu voulais me demander et
banner
[Applaudissements]
elle est allée partagera les lois toi
bats je demandais ce que tu te demandes
si tu veux me demander ce qu'ils veulent
j'ai dit oui ça fait forcément technique
ça mais je veux finir par te demander ça
serait nommé au quai hockey mathieu est
ce que vous nous qui seriez vous pour
aller faire un film avec coma ah oui sur
le coup de chaud non je n'ai pas voulu
faire ça pour quoi si si vous pouviez
danser avec une personne ce soir sur le
plateau ce serait qui bat avec toi c'est
reda oui bah oui sur vous et moi bien
sûr
[Applaudissements]
ou le gaz
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]